reading his newspaper
thomas is shocked by the millions of
women men
children and elderly people that are
facing widespread violence and
persecution for their ideas
for their religion or
for their ethnicity
thomas wonders what europe can do to
protect these people
asylum is a fundamental right recognized
already in 1951 by the geneva convention
relating to the status of refugees it
protects those who are fleeing their
native countries
because of danger or persecution
the problem is that the way this right
is granted and applied in the eu
varies from one country to another and
so does the likelihood of being granted
asylum
in the eu there are around 300 000
asylum claims per year
with 75 percent of them being dealt with
in just six countries
this goes to show how unevenly the
responsibility is shared across the eu
this is why the eu has decided to
establish a common european asylum
system
it harmonizes the asylum rules across
the union
and increases the chances that an asylum
request is dealt with
in the same way all over europe the
common asylum rules will also help
protect
against abuses of the national asylum
systems protecting asylum seekers is not
only about common rules but also about
solidarity between countries the eu
countries under particular pressure
need to be helped to shoulder their
responsibilities
the eu also supports countries outside
its border to establish humane
and functional asylum systems the
european asylum support office
has been created to coordinate some of
these activities
it assists eu countries through
practical cooperation
and provides support in situations of
crises linked to sudden influxes of
asylum seekers
this mixture of common rules and
practical solidarity
allows the eu to ensure that people
fleeing persecution and conflict
will continue to find a safe haven in
europe and that's something that thomas
is rather proud
you